also gestern abend hat das landesamt für
gesundheit bekannt gegeben dass es an
den test stationen an den flughäfen
probleme gegeben hat das letzte mal war
es ja an den autobahn-raststätten gesagt
worden ist die tests wurden alle gemacht
die ergebnisse sind auch alle bekannt
sie können auch eindeutig den getesteten
personen zugeordnet werden wir haben
allerdings probleme an einer
schnittstelle mit der software
das heißt die leute bekommen ihre
testergebnisse nicht schnell genug das
heißt auch dass positiv getestete bis zu
einigen tagen verzögerung erst erfahren
dass die positiv sind
grundsätzlich ist natürlich so wer aus
einem risikogebiet nach bayern 1 reist
er muss zunächst einmal in die
quarantäne gehen und darf das haus nicht
verlassen wenn er ein positives
testergebnis bekommt dann kann er die
quarantäne verlassen
insofern wenn man sich daran hält wäre
man auch würde man auch die umgebung
nicht gefährden und könnte andere nicht
anstecken aber wir wissen natürlich
nicht ob das auch wirklich alle tun es
ist jetzt schon wieder die nächste große
test panne für markus söder was bedeutet
das jetzt für ihn ja das ist natürlich
nicht so schön
er hat jetzt gerade eben zusammen mit
einer großen umorganisation der
testzentren da wurden kompetenzen in dem
innenministerium verschoben
die erste test panne behoben
jetzt kommt das zweite man muss
allerdings auch sagen dass bayern eine
test strategie fährt die kein anderes
bundesland so hat bayern ist immer noch
das einzige bundesland das jedem bürger
anbietet sich kostenlos testen zu lassen
seit märz hat es 24 millionen kroner
test in bayern gegeben sei denn seitdem
die teststation an autobahnen flughäfen
bahnhöfen eingerichtet worden sind sind
bis zum 30
august 300 über 300.000 tests gemacht
worden das sind täglich fast 37.000
tests die in bayern abgenommen werden
das ist natürlich eine erhebliche zahl
und dass da auch hin und wieder einige
verzögerungen eintreten können dass das
am anfang jetzt noch nicht richtig rund
läuft das kann man auch verstehen
das landesamt für gesundheit des
gesundheitsministeriums für heute
angekündigt dass sie das problem beheben
werden